[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what i like to do is do stand up get
hammered and then listen to motivating
rap oh [ __ ] on the uber home looking
over the skyline
dude
dude that happens every once in a while
i'll just get a wave of like oh no it's
happening again
everyone hates me again there has to be
a hot feeling in the face it's
crazy that has to be some [ __ ] heat
for your head i know i've told this
story a thousand times but getting
cancelled i was on a train yeah yeah
yeah going to the stage
and just getting canceled in between
stops
like because i would lose service
and then the next top player is holy
[ __ ]
1 000 new tweets
then the next stop was like
i don't remember saying that i didn't
say that
didn't you say that people were like
people were like looking down at their
phone and then like looking yeah yeah
several times
when i got canceled i had zero dollars
so i was you know taking the train
taking the bag of bus people would be
like
is this you
yeah that's funny it's me it's not going
to take a bus the mega bus from new york
oh man the chinatown bus
that's [ __ ] bad dude you must have
been like you got to be like top five
worst cancels
yeah i mean aside from like [ __ ] yeah
outside of like sexual yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm up there yeah did you play
sports and yeah i played football and
basketball yeah i was just telling
someone do you remember wearing a girdle
yeah when you do you remember how it's
your [ __ ] would get you couldn't
reach it yes your girdle do you remember
post-practice dick how small your penis
would be
almost no one in football talks about
the post-practice stick dude and then go
everyone in the shower is like i'm gonna
go and fluff it up a little bit cool on
my penis i'm gonna pull it out for just
a tin when you were playing like high
school or college sports and the guys
were like uh you know you'd shower were
there guys on your team who would like
work it up a little before they came in
yeah i don't even know any of those guys
guys who would like maybe pull on it
before yeah yeah
what are you talking about you know yeah
i do that before the doctor yeah dude do
you really watch porn in the lobby
you can't show your boys a small dick so
you yeah i would sometimes accidentally
go too hard that's it
you got it it's a thin line
you're like oh calm down you know true
now you can't be too hard for your boys
no no but you definitely certainly can't
be solved true if you're showing your
boys your penis you definitely have a
semi you have some respect for them yeah
you can [ __ ] bulldog women in a pool
dude it's the only place you're allowed
to physically assault with if you can
just choke
dude learn how to take a bump ladies
don't get in the pool dude if you're a
woman you see me in the pool don't you
come near me i don't care if you're
straight
[Laughter]
rock bottom
started i was in key west yeah i
remember that there you're on your salt
life i was salt life and for a couple
weeks and uh
there was it was spring break in key
west so my hotel was just hot babies
and you went in your pool
[Laughter]
i was talking to matt mccusker and he
was like you should cannonball
while the college girls are swimming and
then get at one of those boards and just
starting
rough
waves just by yourself
dude the thought of a solo man in spring
break coming up under
coming up under their floats and pushing
them off
and they'll be like hey what are you
doing here who is this guy ew
starting starting
you guys should do chicken fights
no never what never dude only hotels in
my house really hotel's a nice job
although until you get into the squatty
potty that it kind of sucks when you're
at a hotel you don't i like i'll look at
the trash can i'm like can i put my feet
on this right that's the game i gotta
pour the squatty potty now
yeah yeah yeah it like folds up and you
put it in your man
you got to be a fat [ __ ]
i'm prepared to [ __ ] wherever i'm headed
dude breaking out squatty potty at a
rest stop or at an airport bathroom
washington i crushed airports
i was on planes i take early flights
shooting on planes is is absolutely
insane
wahlberg is going to stop you
walmart's gonna see you going
the move is you go when the drink heart
starts to come
then you go so then you take a dump but
then you're standing in the back waiting
for your heart to come no stretch your
legs no one knows you dumped and you
just you just punish the staff you go
back
take a mess
i've done it before these gorgeous [ __ ]
dude
this is our slots oh and you get to [ __ ]
back there and make the [ __ ] go
all the [ __ ]
i've only flown like once well really
once like darren back but like a trailer
[Laughter]
oh this is why my second flight was
delayed this uh flight attendant just
fainted what and had to go to the
hospital so then they were like um we
need to wait another hour until the next
flight attendant gets here you would
think they could like
just tough it out
yeah
look there's got to be a slot in the on
the flight that'll put the bet
you know when there's like a medical
emergency like
uh do we have any slots on the flight
that can
take over and serve fat old guys drinks
and i divert it that's legendary
so [ __ ] fun it's my new move to
anybody out there that wants to try to
heckle me you're getting hit with that
that's something you hear and you
instantly want to steal it i could do
that you can do it no you'd be happy
that's yours you're in bro no i'd like
you to do it do you understand that i'd
like you to do i think you i don't know
if i want you to do hadouken but i want
you to do yourself [ __ ]
no i want you to do a uh
who's the who's the marvel guy
that you liked you're talking about uh
from street fighter no no i'm talking in
doctor dr strange yeah i want you
to someone starts tackling you just hit
him with like a
dude sending a fireball someone is
tackling you is the best yeah get to the
jokes
it would be nice if you spotted a guy
kind of leaning on his chair and
i mean that would
be over
he might set up a plant and start
putting youtube videos out about
hadouking could have been close
that's like a fake bad fall like dude
that was crazy oh my god guys it's crazy
you should get how much do you think it
would cost to have
security like your own security to
comedy club who would like [ __ ] like
scared scr like jack people screaming
feelings like [ __ ] them up holy [ __ ]
that'd be awesome it'd be a couple it'd
be a few hunch i could give a guy 50
bucks at
most clubs yeah yeah dude [ __ ]
this dude yeah like if somebody talks
get in their face and be like shut the
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] your wife i'll [ __ ] your wife
that'd be an easy fix yeah hit him with
a couple [ __ ] maybe a huger and like
50 bucks
give him a [ __ ] huge give an adderall
and be like dude go
wild 30 milligrams of adderall to keep
this thing totally contained
just saying girl making girls cry yeah
should not be [ __ ] [ __ ] you bad she
has to be big enough to beat up anyone's
boyfriend in the room what are you gonna
do [ __ ] shut up get like three of them
three giant dudes around the table just
three major pains dude
yes and rain hell on anybody
somebody orders too loud be like boys
destroy this [ __ ] guy
you could do this yeah not in any funny
way though no no no like i don't i want
to destroy hecklers without like wit
or anything funny no good comebacks just
for pure violence
they don't kick him out they just stand
around the table and eat his food
revolutionary war soldiers yes and never
stop you have to give them quarters they
will take quarters they will sit down at
your table and start eating
that would be dude i'm telling you could
do this and run a very tight ship yeah
and people be they make yellow chill
with that like if they get caught with a
phone you [ __ ] step on it yeah i
wonder how much it would cost to
maybe rig up some type of pulley system
so if you did hit someone with a
hadouken they flew
to the back of the room you know or
elevate levitated and you force hold
them
that's what i thought shut the [ __ ] dude
that would be so sick
you should go to helium or wherever else
and come down like like nine feet from
the ceiling on the cable
because you could rig yourself up like
if they start getting you mad you start
levitating
if you if you were all black and they
put you up in the ceiling and after the
feature like the host comes back out and
you slowly descend from seven feet
you've been there the whole time you've
been
you could do this dude
how dedicated would you i'd be so happy
what
would be so funny if they noticed me
during the video
during the feature set just on the roof
like a bat dude
you'd have to trick out the lighting
[Laughter]
oh there's so much sick [ __ ] you could
do yeah if you got pulled out and i was
supposed to be levitating but i was too
heavy so my feet just dragged
you watch your whole special or now i
had to yeah i had too much for the edit
very hard yeah i was trying not to and
a lot of people were like you have to do
that yeah i could see that especially
because it's long yeah listening to
something i could listen to something of
myself for like a minute but yeah almost
an hour it's nice to i watched it with
someone who hadn't seen it yet yeah yeah
and that was nice because the giggles
that's right that would make me so
uncomfortable putting it on in front of
someone yeah yeah that's a very weird
thing you ever just pull up and then
halfway through you realize you're doing
it and you're like i'm a [ __ ] psycho
like holding a phone like watch this
yeah
telling a joke
he's from around
long beach yeah so he chills
with trump dead
he calls him his umph dude
he did caleb presley's uh
interview show on barcelo it's one of
the funniest oh yeah i saw clifford's
insane
yeah he's insane but he's like he's like
uh trump wrote this could you read this
and he's like what's up blood what's up
cuz
it's your unc trump
he's like he goes like do you like
donald trump he's like that's my gemini
twins he is super gremlin
it's so funny dude
yeah he calls him a super grandma
daddy
it's also he does have a good song on
there
it starts off like what's up kodak back
he's like my name kodak back but when
you see me i'm white i saw that because
it is so good yeah i saw that was the
part i saw that part's tight kodak black
grabbed his mom's ass dude on a dance
floor what he's a super grandma dude
yeah but kodak black's a little
different than me
true i mean
he's not going to get any voters out of
me
true that's true
yeah unless you come out with a song
like my name's shane gillis but i'm
black
when you see me i'm black
oh that's what the baby said questions
baby was like no disrespect i'm not
trying to be a dick i don't know who
that is
fair
that's a great response who
do you think the baby ever watched jimmy
fallon hell no dude no no
thugs don't watch jimmy fallon no
that barely reaches normal white people
that's literally designed just for dorky
yeah okay true that's like
yeah that's like the nerdiest guy in
every office is like oh perfect did you
catch fallon last night
it got a little heated there the guy
from the office was on fallon last night
i love the office
[Laughter]
that's when worlds collide yeah
when they started making like
what's that guy helms chris helms
ed helms like jump on boxes or something
like that like
pie face with jimmy fallon dude the
office is probably without a drunk jimmy
fallon
alcohol
[Laughter]
allegedly like a raging alcohol
which does make the show a lot better
that's kind of nice to know which does
make because every once in a while you
can see he's got the full moon face like
the full alcoholic phase where you're
just like hey everybody
whoa we've got a great guest wait i
don't even know what's the late night
escape look like jimmy kimmel survives
your black holes right jimmy kimmel and
jimmy found both survived
black face i wonder is there like a
skull and bones for like like
you got to do blackface absolutely jerk
off like the bushes jerk off to you
oh man there's a the guy gordon james
gordon
yeah i've seen some of his videos yeah
he's pretty [ __ ] brutal he gets wacky
i've heard he's cool yeah
first-hand accounts i've heard he's the
man yeah from dudes that have done the
late night like the sketch but uh
man that guy sucks
god he seems i'm sure he's great but man
he's such a
dork dude just like
casey never gets back to him he's a nice
guy he's a great guy he seems like a
great guy but what a [ __ ] game
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
for sure i heard his uh stand-up was
very uh he hit a couple rounds he made
fun of like he would make fun of like
indigenous people yeah he got trouble
for that he had to go to like an
indigenous museum did he really yeah and
look at their art museum
hillary clinton's calling me okay show
me your like beehive thing yeah
you see this bowl is that a spear made
out of rocks
a 10 000 year old bowl
i guess i never thought of it like that
sorry
i know you guys were capable of spoons
friday night okay phoenix
i get done there's a guy out at the bar
and i'm walking by him and he goes that
was the worst [ __ ] show i've ever
seen in my life
and i thought i was so serious i i
thought he was joking so i was like oh
thanks for coming out and he was like no
that was a piece of [ __ ] show
me and my wife walked out and we've been
out here the whole time waiting why dude
i've no i i couldn't figure out why it
could have been the navy seal stuff to
be honest
i think it was
i think it was he looked like tell them
that you were you went to west point
what
no i quit right away oh i thought you
were like
i thought you were a jar hit no
no i thought he was anyway i get out
there this guy hits me with yeah this
looks like i served yeah
that's what i served
so this could have been in the culinary
section for sure
this guy hit me with that was the worst
[ __ ] show i've ever seen he looked
like and i i like
i usually don't get mad but i was like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] like right to his
face in front of his wife and people had
to like separate us after the show wow
did he do anything no he did well either
die
but no i called him a [ __ ] and that was
the end of it but then he has to do
something to you to prove he's not a
[ __ ] i know i was surprised i didn't
get punched he's a [ __ ] yeah it turns
out he's a [ __ ] yeah you you were right
you're
a big 55 year old man who would have and
it sucked too because it was right in
front of the line
white but he was from phoenix so like
dark leathery yeah yeah
there was uh the line for the next show
was right there
watching [ __ ] this guy's like that was
the worst piece of [ __ ] i've ever seen
and then you finally get a fight with
him
and everyone was like holy [ __ ] dude
it's gonna be a wild show but weirdly
isn't it kind it's almost what you want
them to do
like you don't want him to have that
interaction during the show
and i'm sure that's happened to you
before yeah last time i was there that
room really yeah same guy
probably he's like i gave you a second
shoe there's a guy who yelled the n-word
last time i was there white or black
white he was related to shane obviously
he wasn't one of my favorites
no what happened there was a comedian
before me that was black that was doing
a joke about [ __ ] a white chick and
her saying the n word or something like
that it wasn't ten minutes later this
guy's just like how come we can't say it
and the comedian had asperger's so he
was very like
who what what are you saying
and the guy was like how come i can't
say no
and everyone in the room was just like
what the [ __ ]
and i was about to go on i was standing
there just like
the show's over and that ruined the show
he got kicked out obviously
once
he
said
and his wife started chanting biden
wait like ironically i guess like bite
in yeah he was like this is biden's
america we're not allowed to say the n
word in public
liberals ruin this country liberals
you're not allowed to scream the n-word
in the middle of a show
i brought that i bring that up in
arizona next time you're there i'd be
like trump lost here right the whole
crowd would be like no he did it
freaked out i was like you guys got to
let him go dude let it go did you
mention it when you came back yeah i had
10 minutes on it what'd you say you have
to just like michael richards just went
for it oh yeah brother started
bring it back in
bring that patriot back in don't take
him out
he's gonna love my set i was walking
right in chinatown i was walking past
this uh
i was walking into a shop yeah to get
some water and there was a
homeless lady just clearly dead yeah
what like a black lady on the ground
like clearly odin and i like stared at
her for a second i was like
all right i'm just gonna go into the
shop and then when i came out people
were like helping her and i had to stop
and be like what happened
what a [ __ ] dastardly thing to do i'm
sexually awakening you it's like you
[ __ ] yeah bastard yeah you're trying
to come because he dude you read this
guy's book he could have got any of us
yeah this book was great
yeah he's like the uh the waters of
pleasure about an inch deep when you sip
from them you come up with sand in your
mouth
okay you never want to look up the
author yeah i read [ __ ] there's a
book it's called minecomp
and i googled the guy who wrote it
turns out imagine being like what yeah
just discovering hitler
what the [ __ ]
i leave tomorrow i'm doing a show in
philly and then i'm in texas for a
couple
days [ __ ] yeah bert crusher oh okay yeah
it'll be fun you're gonna pop the top
with him i'm gonna drink a little yeah
you should we asked you if you wanted
beers in here and uh dude i gotta take
one day off can you yeah
i really think the taliban could
take over america if they started with
the internet
taliban's got some i will say this got
some okay i was looking at the met yeah
i was looking at the mech gal or
whatever that was the met taliban
wouldn't let that happen
all that [ __ ] and then i was looking at
there was a video of the taliban hitting
a lady with a stick
and i was like i think
[Music]
that's so good right here you know
patrice wouldn't finish his job
leave it right there he'd go i think
and i think they'd have to stretch
before this i think
we need a middle ground middle eastern
studies u.s government and you know
did they tell you who did 9 11 in
college
no
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] secret save vary
what kind of [ __ ] did they teach you
about
well he said yes
i tried to learn arabic but it was too
hard true it was [ __ ] hard do you
remember any words
yeah
you just made that up dude those racist
sounds but no that means uh like and
then there's you know inshallah and then
honestly
[Applause]
yeah that's all uh oh yeah
you're not you're making that's a dog
what club okay
something like that
my brother-in-law is an arab i [ __ ]
hate him
it makes me sick dude
i might join the cia now
[Laughter]
do you see that new cia commercial no
join this year what yeah no oh the girl
one did you see it is it you're talking
about homeland
it basically is really there's a i don't
know what it is there's like an ad for
the cia it's like a video of this
latina woman yeah she literally was like
i am latineck and
she's like i'm a she's like i suffer
from anxiety
disorder she's just like one of those
people she's a woke
and she's joining this and she's in the
cia what the [ __ ]
that why would they why would they and
they're advertising it they're like look
how powerful these kick-ass women are in
the cia wow it's insane well i don't
understand are they dude are they saying
like they're trying to destroy the
family they're gonna take all the wives
and put them in the cia obviously this
is the next level it's the crazy and
also every single military commercial
was like i'm a black woman in the air
force
[Laughter]
having the military be woke they like
just come out of like bombing a small
village and they're like what are we
doing black ladies all right they used
to properly target words while buying
this village yeah they had the best
white trash ads it was like are you
ready to climb a mountain and fight a
[ __ ] dragon
every poor white guy was like hell yeah
are you ready to face your worst tattoo
it's funny but last night my dad my
dad's getting old i was i was with him
last night and he tried to tried to make
it go into space joke and he's like what
are you jeff boros
he's like who are you good
he knew he was wrong and he didn't try
to pretend he didn't say he's like what
he was like who'd you say he's like jeff
jeff boris
who picks up george
yeah he became an old man oh he's funny
just be like what'd you just say
what what
gnarly gnarly people dude that's it's
not acceptable you guys don't take your
shoes off and
no not not to bare feet no of course not
no i'm joking that's [ __ ] insane i
got you know i'm gonna start popping my
shirt off
i wish a lot of people don't do that
yeah that's it just right when you sit
down pants pants straight to underwear
getting comfy
this is a question we've done like
what's the
how do we word it what's the biggest the
fiercest animal you think you could take
[ __ ] like a like an angry raccoon you
think you could beat up a rescue yeah
yeah
on a raccoon but here's the thing about
raccoons you know with your bear
you'd have to get it but here's the
thing you'd have to
be cool with getting bit and scratched
your hands are going to get ripped off
course and you're confident you're not
going to be like ah get away well i mean
i'll do that but is this a fight to the
death or is this yeah
i'm not gonna raccoon if i run into one
right right i mean like it's a fight
that would be a weird vow to make in
your life
we're just with shane going on a hiking
hey guys
hold this real
[Applause]
it's like impossible to be good at
comedy when you're young or like to find
success
in uh stand up when you're young right
what do you think like the threshold
ages is it like 27 or something when
people like start dying from heroin and
stuff like that people around you are
really falling apart yeah some [ __ ] like
that like you can't be
like who's been really famous really
young other than like dave chappelle or
like eddie murphy
a lot of those guys that i think those
guys eddie murphy dave chappelle no
there's a lot of those guys young guys
yeah what are you making this racial i
don't
know that black guys are funny young i'm
i'm trying to make them up black guys
are funny yeah oh at all ages they're
the funniest yeah they are there's no
denying it yeah it's tough dude we're
[ __ ] we're fighting an uphill battle
they're funny
it's [ __ ] tough yeah and they can say
it
it's so funny
i was gonna ask you i was gonna ask you
as a question and it was gonna be a
trick question like whether you thought
you could beat your dad up and the trick
question is if you even think about that
you're [ __ ] trash because intelligent
classy people don't think about fist
fighting their own game
i literally before this podcast started
he and i had that debate uh in the
kitchen today and he
because i you know i squared up to him
and like jabbed him a little and joking
around
yeah of course and then
he he was like i'll i'll [ __ ] you up and
i was like i would beat the [ __ ] out of
you
and this was in front of my mother so
maybe it's not all classic
that's not and she backs your dad up she
backs your old man up like yeah he'll
kick your [ __ ] ass [ __ ] oh he's done
that so one time uh i came out of the
bathroom
and my dad [ __ ] towel whipped me in
the face like i owe he was doing laundry
which is right outside house let's go it
was insane he towel whipped me in the
face
and then i [ __ ] grabbed the towel
and he hid behind my mother oh and i was
like
i was like if joan you better move or
i'm gonna [ __ ] towel whip you
and she stayed still
so i towel whipped her and normally i'm
bad at towel whipping but i [ __ ] it
was a perfect crack and she started
crying
my dad went from like all this is
playful to just in my [ __ ] face
like he hit his girl
yeah he got my face it was just like
i'll [ __ ] you up you [ __ ]
dude my dad's called me a [ __ ] so many
times it was crazy did your dad didn't
your dad sleep in church no that's that
was the old joke in my family you would
hit me well yeah i would be hit
throughout church that's why he goes to
church
yeah you're allowed to hit your son in
charge you'd slap me in church
constantly in the back of the head yeah
back in the day the head or flick flick
to the ear and the neck oh [ __ ] i used
to talk about these the crown the crown
cracks i used to get those all the time
startling dude i hate your heart so much
and your teeth would knock together a
little bit i [ __ ] hated that just
being a father and be like shut the [ __ ]
up to your son just in front of this
church
people people behind you people sitting
directly behind you just watching a dad
like [ __ ]
attention they love it they must have
been like these people are out of their
[ __ ] minds really they had them i
feel like that was normal if i went to
church and saw a dad slapping his son in
the back of the head out of actual anger
i'd be like what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah but do you have your own son at
that point no because then you'd get it
do you know what i mean i feel like the
dads that saw the other dads do it were
like
yeah
it's like enough [ __ ] see that you
see that abusive done
you could have an abusive dad keep
[ __ ] talking keep keep it up keep it
up right
you eight-year-old that i'm making sit
through the homily
a 45-minute homily
did you guys go every weekend yeah yeah
you never missed huh i did i had to go
during school too i went to catholic
school so i'd go once a week ins i went
to church twice a week for like
15 years well 10 years
wow
yeah [ __ ] night not a church too much
too much sure none of it stayed though
huh i remember it
you know what i mean did you in are you
do you have any religion do you have any
spirituality no i don't i don't but i
like catholicism like i i would identify
as a catholic i guess still yeah what
like what about it
what do i like about the what do you why
do you think you would say
yeah why do you think you'd identify
well because i hate abortion and what
texas is doing is correct
uh
i don't know i don't know that's how i
was raised it's more it's like being
jewish yeah no it's like no they don't
be true it's not like nothing at all
you're right
it's like uh
talk to the boss man yeah yeah what
should he what should he say talking to
the boss man should he be like bold
should he be like uh should he like kiss
the ring like should he genuflect or
should he be like i'm the [ __ ]
uh find a medium i don't know
dave at all personally i would imagine
you gotta kiss the ring a little
but here's another thing you do you
could black out yeah
that's a good idea and then let it ride
i was thinking about doing that you
won't even know how the meeting wins
yeah i just kind of find out like based
on his response later on
you get an email that night
you're
fired you're on the plane you're next to
the lady
yeah i toughed it out you could have
taken what's yours you didn't i could
have shoved it you could have had but
dude when you i i haven't had a lot of
fun you like did it there's no there's
no it was me in another unit was two
units between
she had to sit in the middle of two
units we were already sitting down she
she was the last one to sit she was
probably i was looking at the whiff
between me and that dude it was [ __ ]
insane oh dude it was literally it's a
girl's dream dude two units just oh if
we got a plane crash she would have
survived
she would have been in a bubble like the
revenant when he goes inside of the
horse
she would have made it
dude she would she probably the whole
time was wanting nothing more for you
guys just to like fully lean into it
just to feel it snuggling it's like
double daddies dude at once
all your daddy's weight on you there's
two daddies leaning against you you're
flying she was probably like oh yeah if
you could get past
yeah that would actually be nice to just
snuggle for three hours that'd be a new
genre snuggling just like just a lady
getting creamed by two big units dude
that actually sounds pretty good yeah i
mean i've definitely watched that
it's tossing around you're getting
tossed around by two years just visible
displays of strength and when you have
to pen this dude's like tossing a lady
up like
yeah laying on her she's like oh
no penetration but no pain at all just
squash just you lay on the delays on you
just squat
it's just middle-aged ladies too we're
gonna square [ __ ] you squish this
squishy porn you're squashing her dude i
squish and it's dry humping too i'll
squash your lady dude i'll squish the
hell out of a lady
dry hopping dude
dry humping only there's like devils
through some dry hair you knocked the
window out of the lady when you squirt
[ __ ]
yeah you gotta [ __ ] you gotta devils
through some squares that'd be nice dude
that's what this lady got or the guy on
the guys in the very bottom he's like oh
dude you're so heavy you're like yeah
wait till it's my turn yeah lay her
across she's like lincoln
lincoln log just smashing
that's a nice question
yeah so she was dreaming about that how
do you not crumb though
if we're playing like fun wrestling
squash with girls yeah you're gonna get
hard
i also had a boner for the entire flight
the one not that one not that one not
that one a lot of times they say get too
[ __ ] up to finish the games he would
just get [ __ ] up and kind of weigh in
away dude that's that's what announcers
should be i know dude just a guy getting
[ __ ] ripped watching a game yeah now
you have joe buck yeah people hate joe
buck i don't mind i'm right here really
i don't hate him as a guy yeah i don't
like him as an announcer yeah i think
his dad was great tony romo is nice
dude i like tony robbins this is a guy
that surprised the country yeah when
they were like he's going to be an
announcer everyone you me everyone you
know would have been like i don't know
yeah he seems corny he crushes yeah
anytime i listen to him when he's just
like 35 they're gonna hit a quick out
guy bottom of the screen he goes no what
right away just keep keep keep your eyes
on the linebacker right here watch what
he's gonna do yeah yeah and he's
literally done exactly oh it's brilliant
that's cool i feel like peyton manning
wanted to be that guy
and tony romo was like i'm
i'm gonna i'm gonna do it yeah because
peyton is really good at calling stuff
you see but i think tony is so keen that
it's almost scary where it's [ __ ] where
you're like is he is he a genius yeah it
just shows you how untalented he was
he just knew everything that was about
to happen yeah and still kind of sucked
he was ground levels like i know you're
going there i'm going to try to throw
the ball oh you got it you picked it off
damn it
instagram's down right these boomers
have nothing to jerk off to
whatever
my instagram reels are wild right now oh
yeah oh my god are yours mine are just
the hottest girls ever
everything not the ones you're posting
the ones no no no the ones my algorithm
is full pedophile at this point
they blocked me they are locking me up
yeah the chinese yeah
the jack arms are long
tacoms have locked me into being a
pedophile but it is interesting there's
nothing i can do about it do you think
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying to yeah they're trying to box you
in and then get you in trouble
yeah probably
but yeah instagram's down this is how
addicted i am to it like three different
times in the uber here i still try i
kept opening it to see maybe just kept
opening not even to see i'd be like oh
yeah it's closed then i go back to the
other [ __ ] on my phone
go to instagram yeah i'd be like oh yeah
it's down yeah i'm incredibly addicted
but somehow i haven't been on it but
yeah i do it all the time mindlessly i'm
i mean to do something else and i'm like
why am i on instagram yeah i'm on
twitter what am i doing dude you're so
good at instagram
yeah you're so good at it
i'm not good at any of the internet
except finding young women
[Music]
you